these arikaria in southern chile are
among the last of their kind
deforestation and climate change have
caused numbers to dwindle
they're among the oldest tree species on
earth around in the time of the
dinosaurs
they still grow on the land of the
indigenous mapuche pewense people
izaku and chuna and his family collect
the pine nuts to harvest them they spend
days roaming the mountain forests his
aunt says it's always been this way
means people of the arakaria
they once lived in seclusion in southern
chile's dense mountainous forests but as
the great forests disappeared so did the
peounche's traditions
the enchunaus are among the few families
still living as close to nature as their
ancestors
during the last harvest season juanita
unchu now collected 400 kilos of pine
nuts
the pine nuts are eaten boiled or
roasted or made into flour puree or
coffee
most of the harvest is sold
it can be a very hard way to make a
living
we don't get enough money for our
products
the price of pine nuts never goes up
this year the price per kilo should be 5
000 pesos
but no one wants to pay that
no at the same time the prices of other
foods go up and you have to pay the
asking price in the market you know look
at luke
out in
in order to tend to their cattle over
the summer the uenchunaus built a small
hut up in the mountains
they own about 500 hectares at sixteen
hundred meters above sea level at the
foot of mount kutrakutra
it's also where the arikaria trees they
harvest grow
the small livestock farm is a second
source of income
izak uen chunao also hopes to make money
from tourism he recently started
offering hiking and skiing tours so
visitors can witness the volcanic
landscapes and untouched forests of his
homeland
i had the idea to strengthen the
community through tourism
and especially to allow young people to
make use of tourism
so that no one can come from outside
and make rules about how tourism should
operate here
that goes hand in hand with protecting
our culture and our way of life
[Music]
is a great opportunity to create jobs
and new income at a time when many young
men and women are still moving away
life in the mountains is hard and there
are few educational opportunities
of the region's approximately 1.7
million indigenous people more than a
third already live in the capital
santiago
that exodus means that indigenous
culture is in danger of dying out
izak uenchuna hopes that tourism might
help reverse the trend
are mistrustful of outsiders
one reason is that after chile's
independence the military marched into
their territory and expelled them they
were left with only a tiny sliver of
their original land
instead it was mainly european settlers
who were granted land
to this day many forestry and
agricultural companies are located on
pehuence land
this causes conflicts
the indigenous people have long been
demanding their original territory back
and an end to the environmental
degradation
who were once massacred
and that was not all too many years ago
my grandfather still remembered it
it's still very much alive
that's what makes it so difficult for
the mapuche to allow tourism
tourism either it should provide the
indigenous community an income but not
replace their previous way of life
it wouldn't be good for conserving the
ecosystem or our culture
if a community just lives from tourism
then its culture becomes folklore
anyway there is other works
like collecting pine nuts and working
the land and the summer pastures
he's already convinced his aunt juanita
uh
she plans to make extra money by running
a small inn
but right now it's winter so she and her
husband live in their house in the
valley
it has running water and electricity
they also keep their animals here until
spring
they mostly survive on supplies and
savings left over from summer
the couple's four children have all
moved away to the cities
one of their sons lives more than a
day's bus ride away
his mother hasn't seen him in over a
year
as a mother it doesn't make you happy
you don't know how they are
what they need
whether they have enough to eat
sometimes it makes me very sad
she hopes that tourism may bring some of
her children back to the village for
good
but for that to happen a lot would still
have to change here in the pehuenche's
mountainous home
you